[Musique]
à hong kong
m
[Musique]
bah
il
[Musique]
à tous
vous
tac ici même
[Musique]
il m'a gazé en scène
ice
[Musique]
si le
m
[Musique]
il a nié
le vix est né dans l'océan
[Musique]
je
50 avant changement venir l'action à vos
sorts
[Musique]
ce qui traverse les sept mers sans la
permission de lempire de l'océan seront
punis par le commandant suprême
elle espère placer sous l'autorité de la
reine mais saviola musiciens
[Musique]
un pétrolier dans l'océan indien une
plate forme pétrolière en mer du nord
un porte-avions sur l'océan pacifique
ils font feu de tout bois mais enfin
qu'est ce que c'est que ce ridicule
empire de l'océan exactement les membres
des gouvernements à les militaires
peuvent avoir accès à ces informations
la mère qui entoure le japon est la
seule région aucune attaque n'y
il sera trop tard si ça arrive et qui
est ce commandant l desborde c'est un
ancien officier militaire de rendre on
est un scientifique il est extrêmement
paranoïaque il a disparu depuis qu'il
est exilé de son pays n'avons aucune
information sur l' empire
allô oui c'est moi
d'accord
moi et vous avez ma permission et
compris
c'était un appel du laboratoire
océanographique de la fondation du
docteur hockey qui est ce docteur roux
qui un explorateur des mères le court
aux chiots est mandaté pour aller
inspecter la fosse du japon après demain
il faut pas parler que nous
il faut rester secret et aussi
le 99 est prêt à partir
[Musique]
non
le carillon et leurs amis vont quitter
le laboratoire de haut qui en convoi
après demain
[Musique]
je vous envoie le visuel chef et n'y a
aucune raison de s'inquiéter ce ne sont
que des jouets pour notre empire de
l'océan
et qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
le doctorant qui a gardé un oeil sur eux
on ne sait jamais très bien la branche
japonaise fera de son mieux
il faut faire de son mieux mais pour
éliminer un petit rat et si toi tu
faisais le tour mieux pour moi
fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non il doit y avoir quelque chose
l'attend ce str regarde là bas
[Musique]
nous avons besoin d'un mot de passe pour
aller plus loin ici il faut aussi
essayer corrosion
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bruit on ne
bouge plus qu'est-ce qui se passe qui a
tiré deux intrus viennent de sauter à la
mer il faut absolument les retrouver
cherchez les intrus ils sont deux
arrêtés
vérifié tous les systèmes de sécurité
tous les systèmes paraît quinze minutes
avant le départ équipage prêtre année la
passerelle
oui le carton marveaux va bientôt
quitter le port monsieur n'ont aucun
problème monsieur
par contre nous n'avons pas retrouvé les
intrus vitesse minimum en avant monter
la puissance des machines vivant admis
sortie du port
avant vitesse minimum
[Musique]
soutenu tu étais là oui
dis moi j'ai une question à te poser
goro je t'écoute
pourquoi sommes-nous escorté par ce
bateau il assure seulement notre
sécurité ne t'en fais pas pour ça au
fait ce saut mots je voulais te donner
ça avant que je parte sur le court au
chiot quoi mais ce fusil c'est un
véritable trésor pour toi tu ne peux pas
c'est vrai papa me l'a offert justement
mourir je ne peux pas accepter il s'agit
d'une version améliorée d'un fusil de
l'armée modèle 99 utilisé pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale notre famille se
transmet ce trésor de génération en
génération
c'est ce que tu m'as répétées et des
centaines de fois pourquoi tu me le
confie aujourd'hui peux pas m'en servir
dans un petit sous-marin surtout à 900
mètres de profondeur
si quelque chose devait m'arriver je
veux que tu le gardes
il est temps que tu commences à
perpétrer l'esprit de notre père qui est
mort en mer mais je ne suis pas comme
toi je ne pourrais pas aidé grand père
bien sûr que si
toi aussi tu as du sang demain goro 10
mois est ce que cette mission est
dangereuse
j'ai vu des plongeurs bizarre sur la
plage hier et j'ai entendu des coups de
feu cette nuit
et puis il y à cette escorte et enfin tu
me donnes ce fusil notre famille vit en
mer depuis des générations
nous sommes pêcheurs officier de marine
membres d'équipage biologistes marins
tous nous tentons de protéger l'océan
qui appartient à toute l'humanité
mais certaines personnes détestent notre
père et notre grand père à cause de ça
qui sont ses ennemis goro ne savons pas
encore mais cette nuit des inconnus ont
tenté de pénétrer dans le laboratoire
alors cela signifie que cette mission
est vraiment dangereuse pas plus que les
autres expéditions et où sont exportées
par un navire de guerre et un
hélicoptère grand-père voudrais te voir
vas-y très bien salut
bonjour grand père bonjour susumu je
vois que goro tu as déjà fait au cateau
grand père je trouve qu'il agit
bizarrement en ce moment en fait j'ai
moi aussi quelque chose de très
important at dawn et mon garçon
c'est ça et tu vois cette clé ouvre la
porte de lusine souterraine à l' usine
souterraine
je veux que tu la garde pour moi et
surtout ne la perds pas 99 comme le
fusil modèle 99
qu'est ce que ça veut dire grand père tu
le sauras quand le moment sera venu
et cette clé très importante non
seulement pour le japon mais aussi pour
la planète entière ne la confie jamais à
quelqu'un d'autre
la situation a l'air grave mais dis moi
quel rapport avec l'expédition
d'aujourd'hui
la vérité mon garçon c'est que le
gouvernement japonais nous envoie en
mission secrète comment en mission
secrète
je t'en dirai plus quand le moment sera
venu bien il est l'heure que j'aille me
préparer alors je compte sur toi
d'accord d'accord
clé secrète
un fusil
qu'est ce que tout ça veut dire
et les caméras sw 2 détecte aucun signe
anormal
aucun écho radar détecte et qu'un autre
navire est détectée dans les parages
rester en alerte continuer à scruter
l'océan pour la bio cariou marot nous
approchons de la cible la fosse du japon
réparer le bathyscaphe
bien reçu préparez à batiscan nous
approchons de la cible préparez vous
commencez les dernières vérifications du
bathyscaphe karim a remarqué l'an
l'expédition a commencé son show mou
n'oublie pas d'aller déposer des fleurs
sur la tombe de ses parents ne
l'oublient pas je devrais le faire
instant père essaye de ne pas faire trop
de bêtises mme d'accord bon voyage et
fait en sorte de vitraux me récupère est
en cuisine
[Musique]
pourquoi me parle utile comme si c'était
la dernière fois qu'il m'envoyait
[Musique]
ça y est nous
pour toucher l'autre
[Musique]
bah rien changé remplissez les réserves
quant au moteur en marche
en marche oxygène spéciaux des rockets
paris a plongé go d'accord vitesse
minimum en avant
[Musique]
le court au chaud se stabilise il est à
moins 3000 mètres la vitesse de descente
est normal le solaire de l'eau la vie a
repéré le court aux chiots pression
d'huile et générateurs rien à signaler
nous sommes à moins 4500 d'être grand
père j'ai beau regarder partout je ne
vois absolument rien bouger
peut-être que les gens de la défense
sont un peu parano mais bien il faut
dire que la marine était extrêmement
perplexe au début mais il ya bien eu une
série d'incidents plus qu'étrange autour
de la foule japonaise sommes à moins
5000 m
c'est la fosse japonaise nous arrivons
dans le centre de la fausse joie très
prudent
le court au chaud entre dans la fosse
japonaise à moins 7000 m tout est normal
comme tu dois le savoir susumu il ne
s'agit pas d'une simple expédition
scientifique
oui je sais grand père m'a mis au
courant ah bon tu es au courant
et bien en fait nous faisons cette
expédition pour savoir si ce fameux
vampire de l'océan existe vraiment mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cet empire de
l'océan j'ai entendu aux informations
qu'il y avait eu de sérieux accident en
mer l'information est toujours classé
top secret mais l' empire de l'océan
serait une organisation et pourrait même
être une nation inconnus alors il
existerait vraiment mais quel est leur
but que veulent t'ils exactement on dit
que qui contrôle les océans contrôler le
monde
je crois que l' empire de l'océan est en
train d'essayer avec arrogance de le
prouver
goro et le dr lô qui vont essayer de
découvrir s'il existe
cette fois je commence à comprendre
pourquoi ils m'ont laissé tous leurs
trésors
il était parfaitement au courant des
risques de cette mission je ne pense pas
qu'ils seront attaqués mais il pourrait
être pris entre deux feux goro grand
père
sommes à -10 me mettre c'est lotois
critique le champ de vision les deux
moins de 10 mètres 20 minutes avant le
fond scanner coupé hydrophones active et
enregistrement commencer nous allons
peut-être entendre des baleines
un grand père il ne s'agit pas d'une
expédition scientifique cette fois ci
oui c'est vrai tu as raison
j'entends quelque chose de bizarre dans
l'hydro phone qu'est ce que tu entends
je branche le haut parleur mais qu'est
ce que c'est ça se trouve à un kilomètre
de long et le sonar ne détecte rien
toutes ont su bruit les grands pères ça
ressemble au moteur c'est impossible
aucun autre sous marin ne peut descendre
à une pareille profondeur
qu'est-ce que cela peut-être goro tout
car il est juste devant nous je ne
comprends pas pourquoi le sonar de
détecteurs rien j'envoie des fusées
éclairantes
c'est bien sûr
les chiffres de vente
partir quel prix
c'est pas mais ça ne présage en rien je
fait machine arrière
[Musique]
j'ai entendu
ils sont tirés tant pis ou c'est
verticale maximum
[Musique]
stabilis tour auto stabilisateur affirme
avant tout mais ne répond plus tous
blessés puis lectrique 2 à 4 nous avons
une photo la pression diminue mais
ressent face le réservoir principal
détruits
oh non estimant qu il faut vignes et les
ballasts paré à faire surface
[Musique]
même possible
les ballasts c'est la fin
grand père se finira le travail
après l'explosion nous avons entendu un
bruit non identifié qu'est-il arrivé au
cours au trio il est trop profond pour
le savoir nous recevons les kodan autres
chiots par un équipage préparez vous au
combat
contacté le karyu marot capitaine un ami
jeannot nous faire son rapport il nous a
dit que ces hydrophones ont détecté une
succession de violentes explosions
croire kuroshio est porté disparu
c'est un possible gros grand père
oh mais qu'est ce que c'est le seul avis
attention cailloux marron rendez-vous
immédiatement et obéissez à nos ordres
si vous résistez nous attaquerons
[Musique]
transmettez sur une fréquence habituelle
veuillez avant tout avoir la politesse
de vous identifier
nous ne pouvons accepter de recevoir
d'ordres de kira nous mettons à nouveau
en garde au nom des maîtres du monde
l' empire de l'océan rendez vous les
suivez nos ordres si vous résistez
nous ouvrirons le feu sans sommation
nous ne pleurerons pas transmettez les
informations au quartier général
immédiatement à mozart capitaine j'ai
bien entendu il a bien parlé de lempire
de l'océan oui vous avez bien entendu
au sommaire à un non identifié il est
hors de question que nous cédions à vos
menaces le carré oumarou est bien placé
nous allons nous positionner entre le
quart et oumarou et le navire ennemi
nous serons un bouclier pour le carry
oumarou à vos ordres et nous envoie une
torpille virer instruments en avant tout
lit trop tard monsieur sonné l alarme
mon ami est touché il prend feu
le sous-marin ennemis se rapproche de
nous qu'allons-nous faire capitaine
nous avons perdu une escorteur nous ne
pouvons rien fait mais il faut réagir
hisser le drapeau blanc qui êtes vous
stop
on ne bouge plus vous allez suivre nos
ordres ou alors vous finirez tous comme
c'est escorteur au fond de l'océan ne
bougeait plus posée ce fusil sur le sol
pas de mouvements brusques
vous travaillez aussi pour l' empire de
l'océan n'est ce pas pas vraiment mais
vous pouvez considérer que nous sommes
vos ennemis nous voulons des
renseignements sur votre laboratoire
secret qu'est-ce que vous cacher dans le
laboratoire de l' usine souterraine
lusine souterraines c'est exact
qu'est-ce que vous construisez c'est une
arme ou un sous marin un sous marin
mais de quoi il parle nous ne recevons
aucune réponse comment préparez-vous à
attaquer une seule torpille cible à 2 km
droit devant le carillon ma roue il
semble qu'il y ait des espions à bord
commandant ça ne change rien à mes
ordres
envoyez la torpille le sous-marin a tiré
une torpille est bien droit sur nous
ces structures non
non on ne bouge plus marleix dépêchez
vous
bien joué ce jour
les télés où s'arrête la torpille arrive
droit sur nous machine arrière toute
c'est trop tard
sochaux cros
[Musique]
les manques et distances 500 b
quatre sommets
[Musique]
surtout
en 2000
g j'ai tiré au fusil pour la première
fois nous sommes sauvés
voici les jets de la défense aérienne de
manas non identifié nous allons
effectuer des tirs de semonce
la vie est né dans l'océan mais un
groupe de criminels a voulu blement la
police et
elle se fait appeler l' empire de
l'océan il défie le monde
pour ce sunu il est temps de faire face
à la réalité
il se retrouve entraînée au centre d'un
conflit ou des forces maléfiques
l'attend
goro grand père j'espère qu'ils sont
sains et saufs lempire de l'océan sera
moche susumu et de saclay ce grain
quand la clé se révélera
le super sous-marin apparaîtra
prochain épisode le super sous-marin
appareils en avant tout
[Musique]
amélie arménie tas de jobs
beaucoup beaucoup niveau chez
m
dumont
mais m
qui
[Musique]
il
photo l
[Musique]
sokolov
oh
il
[Musique]
ite
il évoqué
ok
ainsi
on se gare
[Musique]